but before the questions come I just
to know that he sent us out with you
tonight and the invitation was
invitation to do exactly that very
visual which I normally don't do the
irony of that is that I grew up as a
photographer in a family of artists I
can really only think visually and
writing is actually kind of a painful
process because i only see ideas and
then i have to figure out how can i
express them in words and so and what's
happened is that I've become a wordy and
I haven't been visual presentations for
a long time and so here I am without a
dongle doing my visual speech without
the visuals but anyway the good news is
the first part of the speech we can bag
some of the visuals and if we get the
thing soon not much would be lost when I
started thinking about this besides I
couldn't help but think about end time
talking about the long now but in fact
the end time is much much with us the
two Abrahamic religions Christianity and
Islam both have time scenarios and of
course we're familiar many of you are
with Hinduism in the Kali Yuga which is
a stage we're in now in Hinduism time is
cyclical but in the Kali Yuga it is sort
of like a spiral or an ice skater
bringing in his or her hands and time
becomes more compressed I have to say of
all the descriptions of endtime the
Hindus get the prophetic nod no question
about it the earmarks and signs of the
Kali Yuga in no particular order our
food will become tasteless check crows
and ravens will increase the numbers
which was true until West Nile virus
which is now attacking them girls will
have babies at 10 years old check old
men will be prematurely youthful
viagra right viagra right check okay
judge and politicians will favor the
wealthy and I thought that was a kind of
a ringer like when haven't been you know
so I didn't think audacity of speech
will be the only criterion of veracity
now who might that be virtuous deeds
will be performed only with the object
of gaining Fame people will be oppressed
by heavy taxation people will perish
through droughts unusual cold scorching
heat heavy rain and mutual conflict in
Islamic and Christian eschatology though
end time is signaled by a series of
portraits which are actually broadly
familiar and almost like a nice mark of
the other the Christians have a knack
for more elaborate scenarios as
witnessed by the book the late great
planet Earth which is one of the
best-selling books of all time 35
million copies and of course there is
the Left Behind series which is also
phenomenal in his popularity but for the
Islamics and this is really pertinent
right now there is a belief that the
dajjal the dajjal the false messiah or
the Antichrist will blaspheme Jerusalem
and read arielle sharone right and the
Mahdi who is the new prophet that will
lead them to a messianic age is here in
many of the poor areas of Middle East
you know as I said Arielle sharone is
the bogeyman that the Mahdi or the
Messiah is either Osama bin Laden or
mullah omar of the taliban right and for
John ash ash Croft and George Bush of
course it's completely the opposite the
Antichrist in their way of thinking is
actually about and alive in of all
places where he was predicted to be the
Middle East and the Islamic Messiah is
in fact in Christianity the Antichrist
Osama bin Laden and according to a
revelation interpretations the
Antichrist forms an army al Qaeda but so
does Jesus and Jesus appears in the
clouds to take believers up to meet him
like a receptor
maybe less escaping the terrible
overwhelmingly destructive Donald
Rumsfeld war that will soon come non
born-agains across from that environment
we are the Left behinds most of us here
unless I made a mistake the point is
that the the world's two biggest
religions have significant numbers of
believers that see this as the end time
or at least at the end of a significant
era and several of them are in the White
House and in our cabinet so what does
this have to do with the long Thank You
Danny thank you so much don't want to
see that yet thank you okay
and the green movement to me are the
stay behind these are people who don't
want to leave in fact they want to stay
here and fix it up and they're not at
all happy with the current tenants the
upkeep d behavior or the landlord
there's a deep sense of continuity with
place with rivers with mountains animals
you know coral reefs you know and
somehow in some way the Greens have come
to integrate timelines into the love of
self and them to their love of life
Janine venues the author bio mimicry
whom I highly recommend for this series
mmm talks about offspring and all
species have offspring and they do
everything they can in a sense to do
what to ensure the survival of their
offspring but they also ensure the
survival or their offsprings offsprings
offspring well how do you ensure the
survival of offspring that you will
never see well you do that by paying
attention to habitat the only way you
can ensure survival lost when you on sea
is by taking care of your place now this
speech the long green was suggested by
the title was suggested by Stewart and
in a flash he also gave me the precis of
speech and he said grote as he said in
his introduction if a connection between
the long now and the earth has been made
it is partially due to environmentalism
or the environmental movement this would
be due to the fact that it is at heart
on one hand a science-based movement and
that science has long lead and lag times
that require the measuring and
understanding of change over long cycles
it uses bristlecone pine cones ice core
samples dendrochronology of course
ancient lake beds pollen samples in
amber the longitudinal data set created
by the amount of lower Observatory on
co2 which has become critical to our
understanding of our climate change
another way to put it is that the many
environmental sciences and they really
are many limnology which is
course lakes and I christology grasses
bionomics sylvac ornithology paleobotany
climate ology evolutionary biology
center college in marine biology etc etc
etc but almost all these really require
long views in order to them to be
effective now the movement itself of
course for it to be effective any
movement to be effective has to
innocence specialized it has to have to
rise above the sea of noise in the
culture and environmental did it with
mostly you know charismatic vertebrates
you know dolphins whales panda bears
have all served the movement well but a
l'heure coated apples and clear cuts and
other things have also helped but the
problem with specialization as we know
is it for fans against integration and
connectivity okay and so the
environmental movement really is has
been in some ways historically cut off
from other movements that actually take
a long view such as historical
preservation movement archeology and
other time-based disciplines you know
and the example of that is at the local
chapter of the Sierra Club for a while
opposed the long I'll clock library in
the snake mountains in Nevada now when
we look at the long green try to think
forward if we can which is becoming more
and more difficult given climate climate
science but we have to also figure out
well what are the roots of it where did
it start where did it originate and the
different environmental timelines or
ecological histories and so forth all
dairy but there's certain i think
elements that we can excuse me look at
and as the origins if you will of this
movement now i've started with actually
George Marsh but this is the guy I
really want to show because i think it
was Emerson's essay 1836 on nature that
you would have to go back to at least in
this continent you know and say okay
that was a seminal point in terms of our
thinking in our relationship to self in
nature it really provided the
philosophical philosophical
underpinnings of transcendentalism
there's no question about that quote who
looks upon a
in a meditative hour and is not reminded
of the flux and all things the currents
of the universal being circulated
through me I am part or particle of God
of course which is a very witness
statement you think of leaves or grass
right but this was actually pretty
controversial stuff at the time I mean
very controversial it took six years by
the way for Emerson to sell his
self-published book 500 copies he sold
in six years so for those who are
self-published in struggling relax but
the fact is that in two years later he
gave a talk that was based on that book
at Harvard University and it was almost
scandalous because in a sense what he
said as an ex unitarian minister who
struck out as a pamphlet ear and a
writer is that he really questioned the
mediating role of church in the trinity
and replaced the church with nature and
said nature was a mediator for 12 for 12
understand oneself in spirit and it
caused a few and and and and the the
church was really pissed off actually
and again to quote from nature the scars
awakened a certain reverence because
they're always present they are
inaccessible but all natural objects
make a kindred impression when the mind
is open to their influence nature never
wears a mean appearance neither does the
wisest man extort her secret and lose
his curiosity by finding out all her
perfection nature never became a toy to
the wise spirit now is really George
Perkins Mars though who is commonly
called the first five Mentalist he was a
state senator from Vermont a congressman
excuse me and he delivered a very
seminal lecture in 1847 on deforestation
which became the basis for his book man
in nature it was published in 1864 it
was very prescient broke no question
about it was also in my opinion way off
the mark on a good side he was the first
to describe the interdependence of the
environment and society and it seems
Elementary to us but at the time that
was not the case
but there is a very distinct and clear
subtext there that it is man and i'm
using a gender specifically here over
nature I mean so there was no bones
about that and this schism continues to
this day in many of I think the larger
what I call megafauna environmental
organizations that are primarily rooted
on the East Coast I mean there's a real
difference between those on the east and
the west and there's Martian
organizations and there's Emersonian you
know Emersonian ones you might say or
friends of year of Sierra Club earth
island ecofeminism Deep Ecology to be
sure and groups who do not see primacy
to corporations or other human
institutions in terms of the sanctity of
the environment Martian organizations I
would say Oh NRDC Nature Conservancy
Environmental Defense conservation and
national World Wildlife you know those
are just my categories Martian
organizations tend to be better financed
they are not threatening to the
establishment and bring them in
wholeheartedly on their boards as its
funders so they generally have a lot
more money they're generally white
they're generally more conservative they
tend to be hunters as a group and mer
Sounion organizations are much more
numerous they're smaller they're lighter
afoot they're poorly endowed as a rule
they're faster acting the more radical
they're collectors they are writers
they're preservers they're a lot more
scientists and that and who are
activists as opposed to researchers but
but you need to go back before Emerson
in Mars and you have to cite others you
got to think about Ruskin and 1820s who
really called a question the Industrial
Age and the enormous suffering
occasioned upon poor people in London
and other cities jean-baptiste Fourier
in 1824 was a one who first for the
theory that in fact the atmosphere
trapped he have sunshine so in a sense
global climate Theory started in 1824
although the Luddites are used as a term
of opprobrium and ridicule the movement
is actually was a really brilliant
underground gorilla
it was really really well thought out
and you see some of the exact same
techniques today in a group such as the
ruckus society that were used by the
Luddites you know so again when you look
at what we had today you can trace the
roots back to in this case John Lud in
the 1830s and then there's Audubon okay
John James Audubon now he was a mulatto
he came here he was an acclaimed artist
but he came here to really dodged the
draft he who came from Haiti and he
didn't want to go to war but in a sense
Audubon was the discovery channel of his
day he was a national geographic channel
his first edition of birds of america
was published was 435 and used most of
you seen these folio but they were
almost life-sized Prince of Ava fauna
was published in 1926 and then sandy was
published in Scotland it became a huge
huge success in the United States and
he's was not the first attempt to paint
all the alien life in North America
alexander wilson was the first but his
work eclipse all others before and simon
says since you know and 1851 the road
delivers a lecture to conquer Lyceum and
which he says in wilderness is the
preservation of the world at the same
time and now we see a shift in terms of
the environmental movement California
becomes really important and and and
what happened at the same time and
tomorrow is giving but that lecture to
Lyceum there was a kind of an
entrepreneur out here named Gail James
Gail George get excuse me who had a kind
of a carnival show and you know kind of
tawdry sort of entrepreneurs type and he
had heard that that in the Calaveras
grove because the gold miners had gone
up there that there was a tree called
the mother of the forest and this was
the most magnificent redwood tree that
was standing in wit is now Yosemite it
was 300 feet tall it was 92 feet in
diameter and he decided with nobody's
permission even though he didn't own a
sawmill or he wasn't a lumberjack that
he was going to cut it down and use it
for his vaudeville show and so forth and
probables back east so he got all these
men they cut through it they cut through
it again they cut all the way through
the tree the tree wouldn't fall they
made big battering rams you know and the
tree wouldn't fall they put in wedges
all in one side the tree would fall it
was so huge it was so straight it was so
symmetrical the weight was so perfectly
centered they could knock the tree over
25 days later a big true Gail a
windstorm came up and blew the tree down
when it was blown down people in the
middle of the night in mining camps 15
miles away or awoken by the noise you
know that was some tree a tree was
twenty-five hundred and twenty years old
a nearby tree which had died earlier
naturally was called the father of the
forest it was 450 feet long 45 stories
right the mother the forest contains so
much water that the needles of the tree
didn't turn brown for five years it was
alive even though there was no roots at
all but the cutting the tree created
this huge outcry and the East Coast
Horace Greeley the New York Tribune said
it was a villainous speculation and
vandalism of
highest order in Boston the magazine
writer wrote to our mind this was
perfect desecration what in the world
could have possessed any mortal to
embark on such speculation with this
mountain of wood and what he does what
he did is he stripped the bark off a
section about this high took three cross
cuts to show the age of the tree and
then left the rest of the tree there
when he put together this 92-foot
circumference bark you know ghosts of
the tree people who saw it didn't
believe it and he actually went out of
business all right so some was for
George Gail 1854 life in the woods
Walden okay 58 Frederick Law Olmsted
Calvert Vaux they win the con they win
the competition to do Central Park in
New York City and what you have here of
course is called the green sward at that
time but still what you have now is
nature within humanity that is it's the
walled garden see I did it that we
contain nature very powerful concept
infuse Landscape Architecture at that
time gardening as well our thinking in
1860 though I think thorough gave his
most important lecture in most sport
statement and this was a talk called the
succession of forest trees and it was
given to the Middlesex agricultural
society and it's not my phone thank you
and but but this is for the first time
somebody presented the idea of
ecological succession in the forest
something we seem children's that event
now write and understand it now in that
speech he said though I do not believe
that a plant will spring up where no
seed has been I have great faith in a
seed to me equally mysterious origin
Ford convinced me that you have a seed
there and i am prepared to expect
wonders famous famous quote i shall even
believe that the Millennium is at hand
and that the reign of Justice is about
to commence when the Patent Office or
government begins to distribute and the
people to plant the seeds
these things they're very very beautiful
quote but the problem was that in fact
he was speaking into a creationist world
so the very same horace greeley who
thought the cutting of the mothertree
was a despicable act and so forth when
started sparring with her oh and op
editorials because they believed that
plants spontaneously generated they did
not believe that for succession came
from seeds and not only horace greeley
but those assertions which seemed absurd
today was taken up by creationists such
as Louie Agassiz the famous harboured
zoologist he was a pre eminent
scientists of the 19th century and he
went right at the row as well
challenging the idea that in fact the
succession of Forest was by chipmunks
and squirrels and birds and you know
random distribution of seeds from trees
you know now the ring this up because
you know that you had the ASA Gray's you
have the Darwins you had two rows but
you have this creation is streak right
then and that's week was theology Trump
science and that is still here today in
our administration in the Environmental
Protection Agency and there is literally
people in the EPA who were running EPA
and deputy directors of the EPA who
subscribe to this way of thinking that
science goes so far but theology crumbs
right science so this debate did not
stop with the origin of species and of
course I don't know you know Darwin to
read who when it's very interesting
because you know a year later Darwin had
basically had said the same thing in
origin of species about species
themselves not about forest you know but
in 1861 who is out here but of course
native San Francisco Carleton Watkins
right and that's the mother of the
forest dwelling and and that's Audubon
beautiful stuff and this is Carleton
Watkins a self portrait of himself
pretending to be a miner I don't know
maybe he had a thing about minors I
don't know but here is this guy going
around and he fashioned he had a cabinet
maker in San Francisco make him this
camera it was glass plates the plates
were 18 x 22 now remember these are wet
colloidal plates the negatives are wet
with a solution he's planning on putting
him in there taking these cameras it
cameras with one other person into the
wilderness and taking these really
spectacular photographs and they were
published in stereo back east and so
people could buy them and look at these
little stereopticon and look at this
extraordinary place we call Yosemite
which was course an indian name and
these really stunned people and east
coast and it was quickly followed by
beer stein this is the columbia river by
watkins and so Albert Bierstadt from the
Hudson River School also came out around
the same time and started paying these
incredibly romantic scenes of the
Rockies of Yosemite and anybody these
are terrible reproductions bini buddy's
been in the National Gallery and see
them they're magnificent magnificent
Camus's and once again you know the
Discovery Channel the National
Geographic people are looking these
things then it was time it was kind of
an oh my god experience for a lot of
Easterners they had never imagined seen
such as these and this is Watkins again
and this is a Bierstadt course and
there's that there's that and then in
1864 because of Watkins and his
photographs and Senator John kaunas in
California California was given
California is given Yosemite and it
became a state park and later it became
a federal park and it's interesting
because in this we see the early-season
what David Brower dude with a superb
series of books published
is at the head of the Sierra Club
because those books also hugely
influence legislation in this country
and also caused the creation of national
parks and reserves you know and I think
had a no small influence in him
successfully preventing the damming of
Grand Canyon and of course is a year
later who is walking around there but
John Muir he publishes his first nature
essay and it's a dude edition carried
forth to this day by richard nelson and
annie Dillard Barry Lopez and others and
after years of walking the Sierras with
Robert Underwood Johnson he forms the
Sierra Club later in 1866 the word
ecology is coined by Ernest heckle also
known for his phrase ontogeny
recapitulates phylogeny right famous
thing even though of course that isn't
true but the meaning that the
development of an organism expresses all
the intermediate forms of its ancestors
throughout evolution and even though
it's proved wrong the phrase stuck
inserted ecology in 1867 then Whitman
publishes leaves the grass so it's a
very very extraordinary period in the
history of the environmental movement
and the connections between these
writers and thinkers and SAS and so
forth is much deeper than I can give to
you in this time just like the the
network that exists right now an
environmental movement is you know 1872
and leaves the grass you know he said
wherever you are at least arriving to
hither to commence I feel to every leaf
the pressure of your hand which I return
and thus upon our journey linked
together let us go this is Whitman so
again there's this amazing integration
of self in nature you know but you saw
first in Emerson's essay 1872 the first
national park John Muir in 1876 God's
first temples how should we preserve our
forests the senator club is founded in
eighteen ninety two
and the same year the Congress creates
the adirondacks Park you know and then
it goes quickly and I don't want to
belabor it Roosevelt in 87 the Boone and
Crockett Club very important thing it's
a wealthy big game hunters and
conservation group Roosevelt who we
honor justifiably is one of our greatest
environmental presidents was quoted as
saying I feel most alive when I'm
killing something all right so I have to
understand that there was this you know
establishment white kind of Hunter thing
well let's save it so we have these
animals to do what with world kill all
right an eighteen ninety gifford pinchot
returns to America after studying
forestry in France finds that the
forestry practices here shocking
compared to the Europeans he establishes
and coins a word wise use okay that came
from Pinchot and of course and that turn
now is used by the right wing right to
justify property rights and over though
it really belongs to the conservation
movement his friend John Muir then is
arguing are you know for was seriously
for preserves and set asides you know
for him nature's value was inherent for
from you it was not an extractable event
for a pinch oh it was extractable so you
get another schism here that is still so
reverberating through the environmental
movement and just to give you an idea of
Roosevelt he appoints course and so the
head of the Bureau forestry so he's the
he starts that department of the USDA in
1905 the Roosevelt establishes the
Tongass the Chugach forest reserves in
Hawaii he sets aside the Hawaiian island
bird reservation Mount Olympus in
Washington state like
in Oregon the Culebra islands in Puerto
Rico Mosquito Inlet and Florida and
under the auspices of the antiquities
act he signed the Grand Canyon National
Monument into being in 1908 and he did
11 such monuments during his presidency
Montezuma's castle gila cliff dwelling
Devil's Tower which is should be known
as bears Lodge that's by the Native
Americans as a proper name and of course
your wits in Marin County right and then
I was seven he's you know Muir again is
trying to stop the damming of the other
half of the assembly which is Hetch
Hetchy which falls into the hands of
political power in 1909 a very radical
pamphlet here called AIESEC Branson
right swim a pamphlet here and
distributed on the street just like the
guy outside was giving people handouts
to come to lecture tonight but it said
Yosemite against corporate greed a half
of Yosemite National Park be destroyed
by San Francisco which was a passionate
defense preserving Hetch Hetchy and
it'll be proposed and now extant
O'Shaughnessy damn the work of
dismantling this dam which is brouwers
legacy is carried on brilliantly and
just faithfully by a run good and others
who are working tirelessly to get your
semi back for us and in 1914 the last
passenger pigeon died and William
Hornaday smith published our vanishing
wildlife is extermination preservation
so here the idea extrication extinction
the permanent loss you know is really
introduced into a common parlance of
course then it just gets rich in 34
lesser brown Jane Goodall Wendell Berry
are all born interesting year that was
49 sand County Almanac
and so forth then it just proliferates
there's way more Douglas wallace stegner
Rachel Carson and Abby Garrett Hardin
gaylord nelson data meadow jacques
cousteau Eugene Odom's of fundamentals
of ecology best book still Paul air leak
at Abby Renee de ball Dana Meadows
Schumacher I said her already Jim
Lovelock of course in the Gaia
hypothesis Stewart I'm afraid has to be
in there and of course our favorite and
beloved David Brower you know and now so
what's wrong with this chronology it's
foreshortened of course many names are
missing well these are honored and very
honorable people there's no question but
notice there isn't one native american
listed in it then where's Winona LaDuke
whereas time gold tooth where's Lance
use you know where's grace Thorpe I mean
and hundreds and thousands and thousands
of first inhabitants you know here and
of course it presumes the environment
starting the United States but that's
not true there's an environment history
in Japan there's one in all over in
different countries in Europe there's
one in China there was one in India so
we have to be very careful here that we
don't see through our you know immediacy
of our knowledge and project that out
and say somehow we started this it was
simultaneous all over the world and
arose in different ways but going back
to the Native Americans just let me make
a point here because going back to
Roosevelt and this idea that somehow the
environmental movement largely the most
powerful part of it really did arise
from the upper class there's no question
about it and but a class that like a
Perkins marsh and so forth really really
made a separation between society and
human beings and nature itself but
Native Americans and if you look at sort
of the native languages from all the
americas you know northwest america and
south
America I mean what you find is a very
very different set of perceptions that
inform their relationship to the
environment and I was reminded this when
I was in Patagonia several years ago and
was climbing with some friends and there
was a very tawdry little museum there of
a extirpated tribe called the iguana or
the Yamuna people and these are the
people that Magellan spotted when he
came around he'll defray go and he
called him beast he called them beasts
because when he looked at them they were
bathing in the winter at the seashore
they taken off their furs they were
rubbing himself down with salt water and
steam was coming off their bodies and he
called them beasts when the checks and
Germans came into the and paid great
estancia's in Chile and Argentina for
wool for the you know the Hobbesian dark
satanic Mills the Industrial Revolution
they were bounded at $25 ahead and they
were really rounded up until they were
finally in one mission Anglican mission
and this mission was headed by a priest
who was an amateur lexicographer he
loved words and his father however was
involved with an earlier massacre of the
same people and so even though they were
there and it was only a few hundred left
they didn't trust him because of his
father's involvement with his massacre
so what happened was that they wouldn't
talk him just a tribal chief started to
tell him their language and give him the
definition of the words he wouldn't talk
about women's issues cosmology ritual
initiation you know certain things or a
taboo because there was going to be
given just to anybody but he would talk
about everything else he got to 30,000
words and the Anglican
part of her died all right now that
dictionaries in the British Museum just
to give you some sense is there's 40,000
words in Japanese it's just 30,000 words
one person all memory no written
language this language has more verbs
than English in this language you knew
read a dictionary is and this is a term
that Stewart coin or Lisa heard from
Stewart is in a sense local science this
is a language and you read it where the
sacred survival hunting gathering which
is what they did psychology you know are
not integrated they were never
disintegrated and so the terms for for
spiritual States the terms for
psychological States the terms for are
all poetically metaphorical of the of
the science of place so eeka is is a
verb and it means lying in your canoe in
the morning before dawn listening to the
rushes brush against the bark whereas
you're doing this running oh god their
word for depression is a crab who is
molting its shell and it hasn't dropped
it it hasn't lost the old Shelia right
so the language is exquisite now if you
take seven people here who are college
educated and lock them up for a week
they'll come up with twelve to fifteen
thousand words this is the Beast that
Magellan saw this was the people who
were bounty this is a language that we
don't understand because what we're
trying to do is bring this together
these are people that never separated
right so in a sense the framing of
environmentalism arose I think and these
are my comments from a great love of
nature but it also came from a sense of
alienation and separation and there's a
parallel history here which I could go
into and I don't have time tonight of
social justice starting again because
just real age but the old Martian schism
persist persist to this day Herman daily
the great ecological economists work as
you know for a while for the World Bank
at that time Lawrence Summers was ahead
of the World Bank he produced a document
about the world about the situation I
don't forget what it was that but in
that he showed a circle which was nature
and inside he put the economy he gave it
to lawrence summers lawrence summers
reversed it put the nature inside the
economy and said that's how you have to
publishes right so there you have
exactly you know the Martian Emersonian
split i right at the highest levels of
the World Bank so and again these the
heuristics that informed it you know
really the powerful part environment
environmental movement were logging
mining and sports and hunting and so
forth but today the environmental
movement to me is gone it has morphed a
lot of different movements have come
together and I don't think there is an
environmental movement as such as set as
a subset of a larger unnamed movement it
has no name and I think you have to bear
in mind that it was until was it
Spangler in 1876 named the industrial
age there was no terms the Industrial
Age it had been going on for a hundred
and seventy-five years and people were
able to do it quite well thank you
without identifying so I don't think we
can name this movement but there is a
movement I'm just going to read some of
the concerns of the other of the things
of this movement now which include of
course environmental issues but many
other as a deposition ecotoxicology
immigration radioactive waste ecosystems
radio ecology agroforestry magnetic
fields indigenous rights emissions
controls rainwater harvesting emissions
trading indoor air quality recycling
industrial ecology alternative medicine
endocrine disruptors international
conventions remediation technology
animal rights renewable energy
neurology aquatic ecology land Trust's
environmental education environmental
ethics social activism I mean it goes on
and on and on and on I can just show I
have pages of these lists right and I'm
not going to read them all but it goes
on and on right and this is this
movement in the end and when you look at
you say yep that's connected yep that's
part yep you know there's a part of you
that kind of knows it is you know but so
what's happened is that there is a new
movement that has been growing and it is
in my opinion the largest movement in
the world without it without question
and you could say that this movement in
fact is humanity's collective immune
response to resist in he'll political
disease economic infection and
ecological corruption caused by
ideologies they are and at the natural
capital institute which is three feet
from stuart they are at minimum 130,000
groups in the world today at minimum
there may be may be off by a factor of
two or a factor of four there may be a
quarter million there may be a half a
million we are not surya we are studying
it right now these are citizen based
organizations they are village self-help
groups they are obviously NGOs
nongovernmental organizations they are
volunteer organizations they address
social justice environmental loss and
degradation on screen here if this works
which I think it will what you will see
is a beginning a random list of 130,000
organizations that comprises movement
but to give you a sense of how big this
is and I've started running it right now
and at this rate you can pretty much
keep up and track it and read it if I
went faster you might have a problem and
slower you could do better okay if you
SAT here for four and a half days you
would not get to the end of this list
okay that's who we are
right and if you look at the names these
aren't familiar names maybe couple are
right and when as we do this research
what we're seeing is unbelievable lyst
groups we are barians you know we tend
to know who is here but even that's not
true I've been in meetings here and
social justice meetings where people
sick she ought to know about you I don't
know about you there in Richmond in
Oakland they didn't know about each
other if we don't know about each other
in Richmond Oakland imagine what we
don't know about the rest of the world
this movement is in every single country
of the world there's no question it is
growing and I don't think anything will
stop it from growing why isn't it more
visible well a lot of reasons first of
all it's new in the sense historically
armies we've had government's Ward
religious have been here for millennia
but this is different there is no
history there's no name there's no
precedent there's scientific experiments
that we pili show how large groups of
people cannot see things that are
plainly evident right in front of them
if they are unfamiliar objects even
though they're there if very unfamiliar
they just can't see them especially if
very familiar things are in front of
them as well well they're very familiar
things in our society our television CNN
and Fox and you know and and ideologies
and all the sort of stuff so this
movement in a sense is so
non-ideological that it is in a sense
unknown unseeable it can't be seen and
that's just a visual evocation of how
big this list is ok but because during
the span of the 20th century we are
going to put the Star Wars music to it
but I thought
Big E ideologies were worshiped I mean
they dominate our beliefs of who we were
what was true what was possible and
ideologies prey on her inner
sensibilities you know and they say they
stock this earth you know cloud and a
kind of existential armor capitalism
socialism communism fought all during
the 20th century for controls of our
minds and it wasn't pretty and we were
told we were educated as children the
salvation will be found in a single
system of course there's a colleges and
biologists that's just complete
poppycock you know we know that
stability and health can only be gained
through diversity and not domination the
second reason is not visible is because
it's everywhere there's no center
there's no spokesperson it's in every
city on earth is in every country on
Earth it comprises every tribe race
culture and ethnic group in the world
third it doesn't seek power it seeks to
dismantle power it's very very different
in fact it doesn't mean as politically
inactive as you well know it means that
it's overriding agenda is to create a
world where the type of political power
that we see now is both unnecessary and
illegal fourth only parts of your scene
and when they are seen they are labeled
by the media they're labeled these are
environmentalists or anti-corporate
their ragtag their marginal door
anti-trade they're poorly funded directs
hippies or liberals you know it's all
true of course but what's missing from
these labels and what can't be tagged so
easily is really the underlying values
and vision that inform these groups and
and this is the point I want to make
because if you look at these groups and
many many others you say okay what
informs this group what are the values
that inform your work your vision and
most of them have it they have six
points five seven ten and they can tell
you right away and they can write it
some of them have it right on their
website if you had a big enough room and
you could put them all in the wall
and then you could just walk and read
them all they'd all variably different
but they don't contradict themselves and
this is what makes it a movement this is
why so different this has never happened
before in the history of the earth no
movement has arisen spontaneously
without an ideology that is largely in
agreement with itself it doesn't depend
on centrality to be effective so this is
the long green fifth is going to win
because it's going to win because it has
better technologies and this is the new
face of the this movement and these guys
are check say about the billionaire's
pick up early and I'm just going to go
through this you know because you can
see like what is this movement now a lot
of these tend to be more activists
because of more interesting photographs
but is but you'll see right this is a
memorial to the farmer who killed
himself at cancun the korean farmer
these are Simona's who were kidnapped
remember in baghdad and thought that
they were going to be assassinated but
they weren't but there was an NGO his
bridges to back that they were bringing
food and did been doing for nine years
this organization you know it's a fair
question who kidnapped him the agua and
their movement against Occidental
Petroleum there's Randy Hayes in the
middle of the street where he belongs
that's a good job there these are
Nigerian women this is Julia in Ecuador
so this is
after Exxon this is the nominee damn in
India on Dottie Roy so much of a car
Marla narmada jose eber obey the rules
and for sale farmers against junk food
educate in berkeley can't buy the head
of the cup of seen movement in Nicaragua
I love this one this is ken crewing and
this one too with a little jbutton you
know it's really sweet and I want to
stop and go to questions right away but
but this movement I it to me it's so
nascent on one hand and so huge on the
other hand that we have to be careful I
have to be careful in generalizing or
categorizing or naming it or saying it
is this or it is not something else I
don't think we know yet but what I do
want to emphasize to you is it it's you
just bigger than the right neo-cons
al-qaeda NRA you throw them all in a
basket this is bigger than that it's
bigger than the Catholic Church maybe
not in the people go to church on Sunday
but in terms of institutions
organizations places and vitality this
is a huge movement and it's growing you
know and I in my opinion it will not be
stopped the problem of course is that as
you saw there's a there's an activist
part and as a constructivist part and
the activists resist the constructivists
imagine create and try to create new
possibilities you know and yet this
movement to me is extraordinarily joyful
can eos ball today told the story about
which I had never heard of it in in
Egypt and long ago you know they had
this sort of story that when you died
there was a scale you know and you put
your heart on one side of the balance
and a feather in the other and if the
heart outweigh the feather then you had
you didn't go to heaven
and the idea was to be light-hearted and
joyful and I show you this because it
says on top of their budget says estamos
can handle you know which and translates
it on their cheeks which is we are
winning right and this was in in Cancun
and to me you know it just expresses the
vitality and the the you know the
Kahuna's and and the joy of this
movement that we are all part of and
that is growing and that we will never
actually may be fully know in our
lifetimes because as I said I think this
is the dominant movement of the 21st
century thank you very much
thank you Paul thank you for writing out
such a detailed speech that's why you
can't exactly give off your armpit can
you in fact the first question relates
to that from Marion I want to raise your
hand if you're here let's bring the
lights up a little bit in the rooms that
we see each other too she says do you
have plans to publish your speech in
some form or posted on a website we'd
love to put it on the long nail website
if that's okay sure it I'd like to clean
it up I mean if you you saw my notes
here you don't want on a website but
I'll clean it up okay give me a little
bit of time on that will put it on the
site also they'll be audio and video
versions of it there that you can
download and enjoy okay first question
of to content from Hilary strobel here
right there and blue what might be the
outcome and environmental movement that
is informed by mechanistic governmental
policy in the United States what happens
when groups with different ethical
standards and agendas try to accomplish
the same things I said last night again
what happens with groups with different
ethical standards and agendas try to
accomplish the same things well they
have a protracted conversation I mean I
think that's actually not only a
question that a description I mean of
what is happening one of the things that
I think is evident is that going back to
language the when you talk to which I do
sometimes corporations
even though we speak in English we might
as well be polish and Greek you know
because and there was a problem because
they think they understand what you're
saying and vice versa you know but
they're there really isn't that a base
that the base of biology in the business
world and Peter Raven who is head of
Missouri botanic garden and was at a
meeting of executives I forget which
corporation but and he was in a black
suit white shirt he kind of looked like
you know preacher and he was very
stentorian and he really took his
fingers at them and he said you know he
said why do you let the wall street
journal choose your science you know he
said we don't let science magazine
choose our stocks you know and but he
really pointed to the fact of this huge
huge illiteracy that exists in
government and in corporations you know
and working with that is is really
difficult and I was sitting next to the
high mucky-muck of Alcoa in Canberra and
Australia and I was saying that
corporations should not define
sustainability should be defined by
scientist and by NGOs and you know and
he was just like he said who do you
think you are you know of course
business will define it you know it's
our business you know and and so there
is a sense you know that if they can own
it and what you're seeing also now is
the corporatization of the whole term of
sustainability they are in a sense it's
like a verbal enclosure movement you
know so once they own it then define it
then they rank and judge and evaluate
themselves according to their own
standards if you're related to that and
a question from Stephen Hill was an old
hand at these meetings if this movement
is so big why isn't it more mainstream
in our political system well
that's a very good question i think it
is mainstream in the sense that i think
that i was at the bio news conference
today there's 3400 people there there's
22 hundred different groups nonprofit
groups that are at that conference now
as you know nobody is affiliated with
one group right so if you look at you
know act and move on and America coming
together to act and you know you look
what's going on in this election cycle I
mean it is extraordinarily active
politically and so I don't think that
the people are inactive but the movement
itself for example there's over 2,000
groups in North America who have adopted
a riparian corridor a stream a river and
what they do is they have celebrations
and songs and parties and cleanups and
fundraisers and they sell muffins and
you know and they educate people about
you know not putting stuff into it and
basically are trying to restore these
corridors they are politically active
but they're politically active active in
the place they are and what you're
seeing is increasing activity but I what
I want to emphasize is that the social
justice movement and the environmental
movement are becoming the same movement
and and so we sometimes just see it as a
resource flow issue or resource
protection issue and it's not it's about
not just quality of life but people
people of color people in the inner
cities and so forth people who are
debated in rural areas are making the
connection between poverty disease
sickness and resource use or
corporatization and environmental issues
and that's a very very powerful movement
together well a follow-up question to
that Paul we just had four and a half
hours of a national debate between two
presidential candidates in which the
subject of environment came up as a
subject never as a word maybe two and a
half times everyone wants I think Kerry
mentioned it once that's pretty far from
mainstream it seems to me is it is there
some structural reason it isn't part of
that kind of debate yeah because those
baits those are ideological debates so
that's the whole thing is like to keep
trying to establish you know two
different ideologies and not only did
they do that but the conservatives try
to establish that this is a liberal
right whatever that means you know and
in that the whole intent of the debate
is a labeling it's a labeling act right
and so there is no substantive
discussion of anything much less the
environment I know her to substance the
discussion of any subject whatsoever I
haven't heard a single dialogue about
anything important to the American
people in for enough hours of debates so
I don't think you can just take the
environment say well it's not mainstream
apparently nothing is mainstream if you
looked at those debates right here's one
from Reed Burkhardt here there is would
you support environmental activism
through business as a pragmatic method
of Aikido activism to further empower
activism toward the replacement of the
profit objective by the fruition
objective-c I said I think I got half of
it
the first part it sounds like you but
there's some terminology or haven't
heard before to further empower others
engage the commercial sector with Aikido
activism to further empower activism
toward the replacement of the profit
objective by the fruition objective I
don't know and we can talk later I I
will say this that the single biggest
influence on corporate behavior is
activism period no matter and they will
be the last to let you know that the
last I remember being at a meeting of
dupont vice presidents vice president I
calm the peas plastic pesticides
pigments petroleum and we were talking
about endocrine disruptors and they had
asked inviting me to come in and talk
about it it says this for reals an issue
should we pay attention should we not
pay attention and of course I was saying
yeah man you know pay attention but and
and they were saying well you know like
sugar it was a big issue solved a big
issue now people don't you know
you know they were just cited you know
and a woman who was a vice president of
one of the peas i forget turned to her
colleagues he didn't look at me and she
had tears her eyes and she said and she
just shook her finger at everybody and
said do you remember nine years ago you
know CFCs and we put our head in the
sand and we stoned out Stonewall that
thing and we couldn't go home to our
kids I never want to do that again and
be ashamed of Who I am and who I work
for you know and so why were the kids
knowledgeable about it well because the
green peas and activist and the movement
right and so without question and and
you know the the spin Meister's will
pretend that you know it's just water
off a duck's back it is not water off a
duck's back and anything activists do to
in a sense make the people within the
organization feel that they may have
inadvertently been employed by a pariah
organization is really really powerful
in the second most powerful influence on
corporations that i have seen Anna
totally as hong-an totally is CEOs
daughter's not sons daughters coming
back from college and saying dad what
the heck are you doing you know
you know and I don't know what it is
about losing the faith or the confidence
of one's daughter for a CEO and you know
all of the two CEOs in the fortune 500
or men so I can talk about but that
seems to be has just a devastating
effect you know on them in terms of
their corporate practices questioning
from Brent Ross here there isn't back in
the long now seminar on depopulation we
learned about new technology how new
technology is possibly separating
humanity from the biological imperative
of reproduction and do you think
technology could eventually unify
humanity with nature and if so what
types of technologies would these be hmm
well the there is a whole branch of
technology that is described by the
world biomimetics by mimicry where its
nature as teacher not as mentor really
and again Jeanine venues wrote a very
good book on it but there's many other
practitioners of it in terms of
materials systems even social
technologies and it's a fair question as
to say and there's a course a whole
nother branch of technology you know
symbolized by obviously nanotechnology
genetic modification biotechnology or
certain aspects of our technology and
even more exotic technologies and it's a
fair question as to whether both will
proceed in parallel or 1 will become
dominant
one will fall away and I think anybody
predicts the future technology isn't it
is is risks great foolishness you know
because you're always wrong but I will
say that I think practically speaking
you know we're going into an age of
extraordinary resource shortages caused
not just by consumption and rising
standards of living and increase in
population but by climate itself so
climate change is going to be the driver
of a kind of a frugality and the
question will be then which approach to
frugality technologically is adaptable
and useful in place and locality that
can be taken up by people quickly and
which ones will be not effective you
know and I see that as the determinant
of where we will go which your branch
will be dominant in this century I mean
I had my vote but that doesn't mean you
know I know I don't know but you know
you know Peter Schwartz who has spoken
here and who did the scenarios for that
forget his name but I mean you know the
scenarios are for climate change in this
century are the best case scenario is
horrible in the worst case scenario is
unthinkable and so that's where we're
going in terms of climate change you
know and and so those have an incredible
effect on our lives I was at a in New
York at Town Hall and I had opportunity
to speak onstage with the Dalai Lama on
the environment is kind of fun and and
in my my part of the talk because there
was a lot of the Tibetan community there
what I said was and I cited the study
Peter done or scenarios and at that time
he was still not released it hadn't been
leaked but it had been leaked to Stuart
me and others and and and just said that
in fact the Pentagon really does have a
scenario for the Atlantic gyre the
Atlantic you know the cessation of it
when agriculture fails from France to
Moscow and and scenario was every nation
for itself and therefore it be fortress
America fortress Canada fortress
whatever and what I found interesting
was that we were at town hall with the
Dalai Lama and there's a lot of Tibetan
community there because these are people
who had been cruelly deracinated made
homeless by the Chinese and they did not
respond with hatred and vengeance and
vindictiveness and still haven't and in
the 21st century we will all become
homeless there is no question about that
what I mean by homeless is that we will
not recognize the places we live in now
even if we don't move it won't be the
same and the question really is who will
we be and we should be talking about
that it's not a makes it joyful thing
but we should get rid of our last
vestigial pen glossy and eyeglasses you
know and to put them off because climate
changes here and the rate and the
rapidity with which it occurs or the you
know the discontinuities that may occur
in terms of you know rapid heating and
then southern cold we have no idea but
what for sure we know is that this
environment this California this Bay
this valley those mountains everything
that these people we talked about
historically venerated and so forth will
change so radically in the next 20 30 40
years that we will not recognize
ourselves as being home and so it now is
the time to prepare for that in a social
sense you know I hate to when I said
that the Dalai Lama turned to me and
said oh I'm very groovy you know you
know and I said well I it's just science
it's just you know we should talk about
if it's there we should have a
discussion maybe the scientists are
wrong you know I'm just being the
messenger here and then what are the
implications
the message you know and then I said
well the good news of course is you know
all emotions are you know I said our
most renewable resource in America were
crises and and and and the good news is
that it's a very clean i said the good
thing about emotions is they're
completely recyclable and and he said he
looked at me turned to his translator
and said recyclable you know he said
emotion buddhism not recyclable you know
and and and the guy next door he said oh
joke joke just a joke okay here's a
question with a couple angles and i'll
do this question and then one more
question after that we'll call it or
anything this is from linda sharp here
we over there waving a pencil of the
130,000 and counting groups that you've
noted are any of these in sync with
Emerson's notion of replacing church
with nature evangelizing quote restoring
our souls by promoting a connection in
nature let me add to that something that
Kevin Kelly has been sort of teasing us
with for a couple of years which is he's
already giggling away down here as a
devout Christian he detects severely
religious behavior going on in the
environmental movement and so maybe it's
anti ideological but what if it and it
was anti a certain theology is it
sliding into another theology and is
that or is that not a good thing I i
think the sacred is always great that's
different than religion so reverence is
a really extraordinary thing and a sense
of sanctity about people about place
about a relationship you know to place
that you can't get enough of that but I
think we can distinguish between the
institute eyes form of religion and the
expression of spirit especially
spirituality in relationship to nature
and I would make that distinction in
terms of the question itself yes but
it's interesting because if you start to
look at these groups it's not as though
there are people saying well let's start
a group you know what what's happening
is that these are all started by one or
two or you know small group first
because something happened or is about
to happen so they actually arise because
of a reason they don't they're not
spontaneously generated like Louie
Agassi talked about the forest there are
seeds each one of them is a seed and
just like Thoreau said faith in a seed
you know they are planning seeds in turn
of thinking of understanding of
knowledge of Education in their
communities in their villages in their
countries in their governments like a
guardian mithai who won the Nobel Peace
Prize and so forth you know assistant
minister the environment in Kenya right
a woman who was beaten you know just
outside of where she is minister you
know not nine years ago you know beaten
unconscious right so there is
extraordinary things happening if you
and I'm diverting a little bit for the
question but but if you if you just look
at the data and you're optimistic then
you're not looking at the data however
however and this is why we're doing this
work at NCI if you look at the people
and you start to hang out and you see
what's happening in the world and you're
not optimistic then you don't have a
heart because human beings are
extraordinary in what I believe and this
is not theological nor is it scientific
but in fact the course that we are
nature and that we have
ability to heal we are in a sense this
immune response to as I said political
disease and economic infection and we
can't see ourselves we can't see it that
way and also I'm trying to do is for a
moment maybe just a few years ago back
and map it and see it and hold a mirror
up to this movement and so for the first
time maybe it will see in fact you know
that itself and not feel as we all do
most of us in our work and our NGOs you
know underfunded marginalized oftentimes
criticized attacked and seemingly not
mainstream and when we see ourselves
together in all the countries of the
world is you know it may in itself
catalyze a perceptual change in those
millions and millions and millions of
people who are trying to restore this
place we love
last question comes in similar fashion
from two from Rijo make a CEO who's
there and from Arthur Young who's over
there colon Oh what does the world look
like if this movement succeeds and
Arthur Young's version is your talk
ended with great hope if Donella Meadows
were able to follow you do you think
she'd portray a planet with genuine
quality of life would beyond 20 50 or 20
100 and what makes you believe that well
I don't think I said I believe anything
and if I did forgive me what I said is
I've talked about is what I see and I'm
just sharing what I see and in my work I
have been blessed by having the
privilege of addressing and talking to
people such as you all over the world
and have been doing for a long time and
as my grandfather said you never learn
anything when your mouth is open however
the fact is that in speakers will attest
time you speak to an audience every
single audience in the world is
completely different than every other
audience there is no to audiences they
were like they are so distinct and
different and what happens as you move
around the world and in this country and
what happened to me was that I began to
get a sense of like that there was
something that wasn't expressed or
understood by anyone when I first did
the work on ecology of Commerce and
steward and Ryan and I were neighbors
and as I poured into the readings for
about 25 million words which I read in a
year and these are books and monographs
and articles and as they will tell you I
got increasingly depressed I went down
finally I remember Ryan said you know we
had dinner once a week and I'd be going
these rants you know about and see your
end of the world and the Ryan once put
her arm around me and said you know Paul
we know the name of a good therapist
yeah and but what happened was that as I
went out and began to speak to groups
all over the world I began to see
something but just in my reading that my
conclusion was after reading all those
books and articles and monographs that
no one understood the rate and breadth
of environmental loss and degradation
the world it was impossible it was just
not possible and that was sort of
sobering but as I as I said as I travel
I had the opposite realization which is
nobody understands the rate and breadth
of humanity's response to this right
none of us do it's impossible you know
and that is what gave me you know so
much hope hope is different than a
belief that something will happen and in
yours hence you know if you ask me to
draw a scenario I mean I was very easy
things that I get really bad and be a
lot of suffering a lot of loss I don't
think we'll have the same population as
you do now in 4050 years and it won't be
higher you know so it's not as though
it's a bed of roses going to have its
really really going to be difficult in
my opinion and given the facts that i
know but what gives me as i say great
heart and hope you know is you you did
it's that simple and i have had the
opportunity to see more use in my last
12 15 years and maybe some of you have
and that has been like a extraordinary
as i say blessing in my life for which I
am will always be grateful and I thank
each and one each and every one of you
and I know
many of you here or what you stand for
for which for what you up hold for what
you honor thank you very much
you